[Applaus]
neuer superheld es da mein einziger
wunsch ist es den wechsel zu stoppen das
ist mein hauptziel ihn lieben
ich bin ein bisschen verrückt aber wir
brauchen leute die ein bisschen verrückt
sind und für wirbel sein
[Musik]
nein
viele menschen haben aus guten gründen
für den bhc rexit gestimmt aber oft sind
die gründe die sie nennen auf die
britische innenpolitik zurückzuführen
und tatsächlich ergreift die eu
maßnahmen um diese probleme zu beheben
[Musik]
exit ist ein nationales desaster
er ist ein abschiedsbrief eine tragödie
und er muss gestoppt werden
und er hasst du bist
[Musik]
alles montagues des denkmals kommt
krismer
si
[Musik]
mein name ist madeleine ok ich bin 23
jahre alt ich bin grafikerin autorin und
politische aktivistin ausstaffiert wir
beschriften jetzt postkarten und
schicken sie an menschen in brüssel mit
einer botschaft der solidarität der
hoffnung einheit und zusammengehörigkeit
für die zukunft der eu und
großbritannien in der eu
meinen ersten song habe ich am 24
geschrieben einen tag nach dem
referendum das war der erste protest
song den ich je geschrieben habe
mich hat das alles inspiriert vielleicht
brauchen wir etwas einfaches ich sehe
schon wie riesige gruppen von
demonstranten oder ganze hallen voller
schulkinder mitklatschen
großbritannien ist den euro also
akzeptiert diese tatsache
[Musik]
berlin
wieso sollte irgendjemand für den
austritt stimmen
das macht keinen sinn ich hätte nie
gedacht dass das eine gefahr sein könnte
als es passierte war ich schockiert und
ich habe mich gefragt wie konnte es
soweit kommen
[Musik]
warum sorry
univ doz
die kopplung mit brixworth
das problem mit dem brett cit war dass
keiner wusste was es ist die
rahmenbedingungen war nicht klar da
stand nur die frage im raum was ist der
brh exit eigentlich und die antwort
lautete rexit ist als exit wir wissen
nicht was es bedeutet und wir werden es
wahrscheinlich erst nach den
verhandlungsgesprächen verstehen wenn
wir einen endgültigen dealer wenn ich
mit menschen spreche die für den
austritt sind merke ich öfters dass sie
die eu nicht verstehen dass ihre meinung
von fehlendem wissen kommt
[Musik]
ich habe 24 gründe für den verbleib in
der eu gemalt es gibt viele mehr aber es
sollte ein adventskalender werden
am wichtigsten sind die 44 jahre frieden
zwischen ländern die immer wieder in
kriege verwickelt waren
dann sind da noch die maßnahmen gegen
den klimawandel muss plus das
beliebteste programm der eu und der
zugang zum markt
[Musik]
die nikkei ging es im grunde genommen
geht es darum ideen und wissen zu teilen
mit meinem aussehen versuche ich
aufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen
ich trage ein lächerliches supergirl
outfit damit die leute stehen bleiben
und gucken
[Applaus]
ihr kennt mich aus dem fernsehen
das hier ist mein superhelden plakat
da ist auch ein schwert drin damit kann
ich die konservativen und drexhage
wähler abwehren und das ist mein kostüm
ich habe sterne drauf genäht damit es
wie eine eu-flagge aussieht eine zeit
lang habe ich einen piraten outfit
getragen als eine art saboteur aber das
wollte ich ändern
lisa weiß auch wie man das problem mit
der remane kampagne war dass es um
angstmacherei ging den leuten wurde nur
erzählt was alles schlimmes passiert
wenn wir aus der eu austreten
damit können die menschen nicht anfangen
das geht bei denen links rein und rechts
wieder raus aus projekt angst muss
projekt spaß gemacht werden
[Musik]
mein vater unterstützt mich sehr
der rest meiner familie ist zwar pro eu
sie sind aber keine aktivisten
sie halten mich für etwas verrückt ich
bin ein bisschen verrückt wir brauchen
aber leute die ein bisschen verrückt
sind und für wirbel sorgen
das ist das erste mal dass ich das
vergnügen habe meine hand in dieser
teresa zu stecken
die britische politik gibt so viel her
boris johnson ist ein echter witz ein
richtiger auf die klauen
[Musik]
diese passen
ich weiß nicht wie sie als mensch so ist
ich habe sie nie getroffen will ich auch
nicht ich bin mir sicher dass ihr mann
sie liebt ihre entscheidungen als
premierministerin sind aber katastrophal
vor allem für die menschen für die sie
angeblich einstieg einer meiner songs
heißt strong and stable und eine
textzeile lautet
[Applaus]
denn das ist quasi das einzige was sie
machen
[Applaus]
man kann ihn nicht vertrauen dem
konservativen
[Musik]
das hier ist theresa may be the exit
land einer alice im wunderland parodie
eigentlich ist es für erwachsene aber
kinder scheinen es auch zu mögen
die charaktere sind alle politiker hier
ist theresa may die ins bregtal noch hin
abfällt
das ist unser außenminister schmiedel
boris und titelchancen
und dann gibt es auch noch einen
amerikaner der auf seiner mauer sitzt
leider fällt darunter schlägt sich den
kopf auf und sein ego fließt als alle
gelbe klebrige flüssigkeit auf dem boden
[Musik]
univ
ja
vor
[Musik]
wir werden nicht mehr großbritannien
sein sondern klein england unsere
umgangsformen verändern sich bereits wir
sehen einen anstieg von hass verbrechen
ausländer fühlen sich nicht mehr
willkommen
als teil unserer kultur großbritannien
wird sich infolge des brh exits
verändern
und ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich zu
diesem land gehören möchte
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
bin ich auf demonstrationen gehen sieht
man mich oft in anna juni an jack jacke
weil ich stolz bin britin zu sein
ich liebe dieses land die landschaft ich
liebe unsere kultur
aber ich bin auch europäerin es ist
nicht entweder das eine oder das andere
wir sind beides jetzt singe ich eine
lustigen song
es ist der titanic titelsong der brh
exit titanic titelsong
[Musik]
nein
er ist
[Musik]
bis 4
da
[Musik]
der brh exit kann noch gestoppt werden
wir brauchen ein weiteres referendum nur
dieses mal müssen die rahmenbedingungen
und die fristen klar sein
die aushandlung eines deals kann zwei
bis fünf jahre dauern und all die jungen
leute die beim referendum 2016 nicht
wählen konnten sollten jetzt das recht
haben über ihre zukunft abzustimmen
[Musik]
ich höre noch nicht und wenn der blick
sieht tatsächlich eintritt dann verlasse
ich wahrscheinlich das land wird einfach
eine tragödie
[Musik]
beim alten